pour nous il est vraiment une aventure
l'après 1er juillet il habite le
quartier longue pointe depuis 12 ans
jean-sébastien guénette l'a choisi pour
sa tranquillité mais l'arrivée d'un
refuge pour personnes sans abri à deux
pas de chez lui a tout changé depuis
quelques semaines on trouve des
seringues abandonnées dans le quartier
en autour des sachets de retour dans nos
cours on voit de la prostitution 120
itinérant habite temporairement à
l'auberge royal versailles c'est que le
centre pierre charbonneau où il logeait
à fermer ses portes et que le refuge
doit déménager c'est pas l'idéal mais
l'idéal c'est qui a pas d'itinéraire
l'organisme care est en charge du refuge
le directeur général savait que la
cohabitation serait complexe mais trouvé
la solution elle est encore plus à l'est
dans tous les grands refuges y vivent
tout sûrement ce genre complexité l'eau
autour d'eux de cohabitation on
travaille avec les citoyens pour leur
expliquer mais les citoyens ne se
sentent pas entendus et ce malgré des
appels répétés aux différentes instances
gouvernementales
c'est clairement du tennis de table
administratif on est balancé à droite et
à gauche sans réelle réponse les
services de police de la ville de
montréal affirme porter une attention
particulière au métro radisson en plus
de patrouilles et régulièrement le
secteur la ville de montréal est aussi
impliqué dans le dossier on est très
compréhensive de la situation que vivent
les résidents cependant écouter la
décision d'ouvrir une telle ressource
dans l'est c'est parce qu'il y avait de
grands besoins l'intervention et se
passe maintenant et on espère qu'un
équilibre va pouvoir se trouver très
rapidement l'eau tour de la ressource
les recherches se poursuivent activement
pour trouver un lieu permanent la
direction régionale de la santé publique
confirme que le bail pour l'auberge
royal versailles se termine le 30
octobre mais une fois passée cette date
les besoins dans le quartier resteront
grands on estime qu environ 300
personnes sans abri vivent dans mercier
hochelaga maisonneuve
ici qui me permette radio canada
montréal